hello there welcome to our show of
course I'm Conan we're coming to you
once again from the Largo theater here
in Hollywood in Los Angeles and I'm very
excited because for the first time since
the kovat outbreak I'm joined in person
by my pal Andy Richter Andy's with us
hey Andy I'm over here where I know back
here it's hi okay if I take my mask off
right yes I think we're not only six
feet apart I think we're about 36 feet
apart right as as you requested I
requested that long before kovat yes and
people can't tell but there's a wall of
Plexiglas in front of me that we that
we've really spent a like three hours
making it lighting it so you can't see
it yeah we broke into seven different
Applebee's and stole the Plexiglas from
their salad that's your dream of a
perpetual sneeze guard around your life
is coming true
how are you this is the first time you
and I have been together and you know
you're looking well thank you yeah no
I'm pretty good you know I've been
packing on the pounds just you know for
the nuclear winter that's coming you
know other than that hair's getting long
yep yep my freak flag fly
you too I see you my hair's gotten
shaggy when I if I let it go it
collapses if I comb it up into a
pompadour wave it becomes a tsunami yes
crazy tsunami we frightened some people
have said recently online that they're
frightened so I don't know what to do
but I like it I kind of like just
letting it go yeah this is a time to
explore different hair styles possibly
different sexual what I don't know you
just stopped
you said sexual then he just came to a
screeching halt I know I think I got too
real for a second and then now well and
this is the point where we cut out five
minutes of you just crying now here's my
question you don't have to be that far
away from me why are you that far away
just to be safe I mean that's not being
safe I know it you've been talking to
people mostly on zoom' but you get a lot
of riffraff on this show so who knows
like what do you got let's go yeah that
guy's probably just soaked with kovat
[Laughter]
yeah let's go is kind of a sketchy
character yeah yeah yeah sure is this is
what I like you thirty six feet away
from me that's right that Indians in row
ll4 liking it or looser okay that's our
show we'll see you tomorrow I'm now
gonna walk towards Andy Andy you have to
keep the same distance away from me oh
all right you're a lot faster than me
though go slow
[Music]
it's not same
[Music]